esta sentencia llega en un momento que
posiblemente nadie se la esperaba
especialmente las familias de las
víctimas de ese avión que fue derribado
el 8 de enero del 2020 días después de
que un dron estadounidense asesinara al
general de las fuerzas tiranías
casensoleimanía después de haber
aterrizado en el aeropuerto de Bagdad
aquel día irán atacaba a las fuerzas
norteamericanas en una de sus bases en
la provincia de ambar con diferentes
misiles pero sus generales se negaron a
cerrar el espacio aéreo Así que horas
después de este ataque de partía o salía
de Teherán un avión ucraniano con 176
personas a bordo la mayoría de ellos
iraníes y la mayoría de ellos habitantes
de Canadá muchos de ellos también
ciudadanos canadienses todos ellos
murieron y desde entonces las familias
de las víctimas han pedido que se lleve
a cabo este juicio pero consideran que
no es Irán el país apropiado para
hacerlo De hecho cuando se conoció la
sentencia ayer han dicho que esto es
lamentable esta sentencia una persona de
la cual no se conoce su nombre quién
estuvo a cargo de apretar el botón y
lanzar esos dos misiles recibió 13 años
de cárcel tres de ellas por asesinato no
intencionado y diez por no haber seguido
las órdenes de la comandancia o por lo
menos no haber preguntado a la
comandancia qué hacer los nueve de ellos
restantes que se recibieron en
sentencias entre tres y un años son
pertenecientes al sistema de defensa
iraní esto lo que hace es aún más
ahondar esas diferencias entre Ucrania e
Irán que ya existían como consecuencia
del derribo de este avión en su momento
hubo grandes diferencias para entregar
la caja negra y ahora esto se ha hecho
mayor en los últimos meses desde que
Irán da drones iraníes al gobierno ruso
con el que atacan a Ucrania